DOUG LIPP: Welcome.
Thank you for being here today.
And I would like to share
with you some thoughts.
And [? Marjay ?] talked a
little bit about my background--
a bit more is I
work for Disneyland.
My first job at Disney,
outside of being an intern,
was as a Japanese interpreter.
My second language
is Japanese, and I
was doing some work
for the newly hired,
newly brought on
board executives
from Japan that were
going to be starting
our first international
theme park.
So while I was a college
student working at Disneyland,
I was studying Japanese.
And I knew that they
were going to go
into the international market.
But I wasn't sure
when and where.
And when I was in
grad school in Tokyo
I got a message from a colleague
who said they decided on Tokyo.
So I knew I had to come back.
And the first thing out
of the executive's mouth,
he said, well, you
know, Disney's style
is you've got to
start at the bottom.
So you can either start as
a ride operator, a street
sweeper, or an interpreter.
And I said I'll
be an interpreter.
That's what I'm doing.
And I got exposed to the men and
women who ran the university.
I got to work with a
lot of great people
and start a whole new project.
And you know what it's
like to start new things.
You wear lots of hats.
So I went from Disneyland
and then I went to Japan.
I was transferred back to
Japan for several years.
So I got to live in Japan
as a starving student and as
a ridiculously overpaid expat.
And it's a lot better to be
a ridiculously paid expat.
And I spent several years
there getting the park up
and running.
And I'll share with you a
couple of stories from that.
And then I came back, and I
went to Disney headquarters,
which is their studios.
And the whole time I was
in the Disney organization,
I was exposed to
men and women who
worked directly
with Walt Disney.
Now, you probably don't
realize how blessed
you are to be in
such a young company.
What are you celebrating--
Sweet 16 this year, right?
And you have contact with
Larry, with Sergey, with Eric.
I never got to meet Walt Disney.
Walt Disney passed away
in 1966, and in those days
they were not hiring
11-year-olds to run
the company.
But the men and women
that mentored me did
get to work with Walt.
So I'm going to share with
you some thoughts about that
as we go along.
Is the slide-- woohoo!
That's why your heads are
going like this right now.
As that gets set
up and running, I
want to share with you
something else just
to set the tone for what
an amazingly qualified guy
I am to be speaking
to you today.
You know, you at Google
are so cocky about how
cool your culture is
and how fun it is.
You got nothing on Disney.
When I worked at the studios,
I participated in a voice
contest-- a voice contest-- we
lovingly called it a quack-off.
Think about that.
You can't say that
word in Missouri,
but you could say in California.
I participated in
a voice contest
to celebrate Donald
Duck's birthday.
This was put on by what's
called the Mickey Mouse Activity
Center, which is the activity
center for all the employees.
You have all the
recreation, canoe races,
all kinds of stuff, right?
It makes Googleplex look
like a boring library.
And I participated in this
only because the woman who
was in charge of putting it
on had kind of caught my eye.
I thought she was kind of cool
looking, and she kept saying,
would you please participate
in the quack-off?
We need more quackers.
We need to have
more participants.
And I thought, well,
maybe if I participate,
you'll go on a date with me.
So I did, and I won
the competition.
And I won the girl,
and she's actually
in the back of the
room right there
in that beautiful blue dress.
Hello, [INAUDIBLE]!
Actually, it was kind of
a surreal environment.
The man who was the
emcee of the activity
was the voice of Mickey Mouse.
Well, at the time, the guy who
was the voice of Mickey Mouse
was about 6' 3",
had a full beard.
He looked like a lumberjack,
[MICKEY MOUSE IMPRESSION]
but he talked like this.
So it was really surreal to
look up at this giant guy
and think, oh my
gosh, that's Mickey.
And the man who had been the
voice of Donald for years
was going to retire.
He was in his mid '80s.
His name was
Clarence Ducky Nash.
And so we participated in
this quack-off and I won.
(DONALD DUCK IMPRESSION)
Hello, everybody.
How are you today?
Ah-- ah-- ah-choo.
[APPLAUSE]
And the guy who came
in second is now
the voice of Donald Duck.
Go figure.
But anyway, I really want
to think about-- this is up
and running now? [? Marjay, ?]
thank you-- leadership, service
magic.
I'm going to share with you
some thoughts today about both
my career Disney,
but more importantly,
some of the lessons
that I learned,
and they are in this
bestselling book.
You can use it as a door stop.
You can use it as a sleep aid.
It's really cool.
No, actually,
based on subsidies,
you guys have a
pretty good dealer.
And I just want to let
you know, for those of you
that buy this book,
we are donating
all proceeds to an organization
called NAMI-- National
Alliance on Mental
Illness-- to help reduce
the stigma associated with that.
But in here I have quotes.
I have ideas from
many men and women,
but in particular,
the man who I referred
to earlier as the
mentor that helped me
for many, many years--
a guy named Van France.
Van France was hired directly
by Walt Disney in early 1955.
Disneyland opened
in July of '55.
And Walt was smart
enough to realize
that he and his team of
designers, architects,
construction people,
ride engineers,
were architects of
things, of science.
And they needed a person to
be the architect of people
development.
Much like you have a
chief cultural officer--
HR director-- Van
France would've
been the chief cultural
officer of the day.
And he's the one who started
the Disney University.
It wasn't known as the
University originally,
but he's the man who
created the university.
So I want to share with you some
thoughts about what Van brought
to the table and compare
and contrast, seriously,
the amazing culture
that you belong to.
You think about Googlers and
Nooglers and Googleplex and all
of the vernacular that
this young company
has created in such a
short amount of time.
You have to have a
tremendous amount of pride.
I feel the same
way about Disney.
We had our own vernacular
which has lived--
Disneyland is going on 60
years of age now-- cast member,
on-stage, backstage,
good show, bad show.
But here's the point.
The culture is a lot
more than just words.
It's a lot more than
fanciful colored bikes.
It's a lot more
than free lunches.
It's a lot of hard work.
And I'll share with
you briefly how
we squandered that at Disney.
We actually almost
lost the entire company
not once, but twice,
in a 20-year period,
despite the name recognition,
the international brand,
and love for all the characters
and all the attractions we'd
built, and movies and songs
and that sort of thing.
So yes, enjoy your
unique culture
and your position in
the world and constantly
being put on a
pedestal and recognized
as one of the best employers
in the world and to have such
a great environment
in which to work.
I envy you.
Enjoy it while you
have it right now.
Enjoy it in your youth.
Enjoy it as you
get older, as well.
So I'm going to share with
you a thought from Van
France in this slide I've
got right now-- capturing
hearts and minds fosters
trust and innovation.
Again, Walt Disney
was smart enough
to realize that his team and he
had to focus on the hardware,
on the rides, and
on the attractions.
But who was going to
get those cast members
on board that were
going to create
the happiest place on earth?
People that didn't know a
thing about theme parks,
because theme parks had
not yet been invented.
16-year-olds to 85-year-olds,
and everything in between--
how do we do that?
And so Van created
this environment.
And he learned that that
environment existed for decades
before he ever saw Disneyland.
Let me read one little
excerpt from the book
that I use to kind of set
the tone for what Van walked
into when he realized that
his own quirky sense of humor
was going to fit in
perfectly with Walt Disney's
quirky sense of humor.
So I say in here, "Van
first met Walt in 1954.
Then he was asked
to join the company.
He said, I was asked
to meet Walt Disney.
And the meeting was held
in the animation building."
This is where all the artists
reside at the Disney Studios
in Burbank, California.
"The meeting was held in
the animation building,
home to all the artists.
And it's also were Walt's
office was located.
I parked in the visitor's
lot and set off on foot
down Snow White Lane,
past Dopey Drive,
until I came to Mickey Mouse
Avenue and the studio's
three-story animation building."
This is from a man who worked
in World War II factories.
He worked in aluminum
smelting plants.
He worked in anything
but a fun environment,
but he was an irascible
character himself.
In fact, one of the
ways the we described
Van France to our
fellow colleagues
who never got a
chance to meet him,
was he was a combination of
a Snow White-kind of person,
but really he was more
like Mary Poppins.
He was beautiful
in soul and spirit.
And he was a guiding
light like Mary Poppins.
He was like Jiminy
Cricket guiding Pinocchio
down the right path.
So we kept us on track to keep
Walt Disney's dream alive.
But he was also like
an angry Donald Duck.
And Donald's known to
have a short temper.
And if you gave excuses,
he would get in your grill
immediately and let you know
in no uncertain terms what
was wrong and how
you had to fix it.
In fact, one of Walt's
favorite quotes-- and Van
taught this to me-- was "don't
come to me with no, because.
Come to me with yes, if."
And that opened up
all kinds of doors
of creativity and opportunity.
So this thing about capturing
hearts and minds-- and one
of the things we tried
to do-- and I think
did it pretty well in
the Disney University--
when we would have new
hire orientation every week
before a busy season at
Disneyland or Walt Disney
World.
We'd have 60 to 80
to 90 new hires.
We didn't call then
Nooglers like you do,
but they were just called
new hires-- new cast members.
And we had eight hours
to inculcate them,
to get them excited.
And in addition a sprinkling
a lot of pixie dust
on their heads, we did
a lot of other things
to capture their
hearts and minds.
And one of the most
important things that we did
was this-- we talked about
the importance of teamwork,
of cleanliness, and friendliness
that our customers paid
a premium for.
They'd pay a premium to come
to Disney, because it's clean.
It's safe, and the rides work.
Yes, Universal Studios might
have faster, sexier rides,
but they break
down all the time.
And they might have more
employees, but they're snarky.
If you ask a Universal
employee, where's the washroom,
they're going to
say, it's over there.
Can't you smell it?
But if you ask a
Disney employee,
they're going to stop.
They're going to look at
you, and say, sir, ma'am,
it's right this way,
with an open palm.
But we would talk about this.
We would show videos.
But it's still at
the cognitive level.
It's just at the brain level.
How do we capture their hearts?
And so the last
hour of orientation,
we would take them
through the park.
We would talk about
the architecture.
We would talk about the
theming, but our primary goal
was for them to see
with their own eyes
multiple examples of
non-custodial personnel bending
over and picking up
trash, executives going
to and from staff meetings,
cast members-- obviously
not custodians-- going
to or from breaks,
bending over and
picking up trash,
and as soon as my
new hires saw that, I
know that I've
captured their hearts.
Now they're thinking,
oh, yes, what
they talked about there in
the Never Never Land of Disney
University actually happens.
Where, all too often
I see organizations--
and I'm not saying Google--
but a lot of organizations
try to emulate the Google
culture, the Disney
culture, and metaphorically--
like I have on the slide here--
try to put up a coat of paint
on a dilapidated, run-down
building.
The culture isn't strong,
or it's not even set up yet.
But they think just by
having fanciful names,
colorful t-shirts, or
really cool posters
on the wall, that'll
make people buy in.
Ultimately those posters
become the butt of jokes
if people aren't living
and breathing that culture.
To this day, I can't
walk across the property,
see a piece of
trash on the ground,
and not go into the automatic
robot rote of must bend over
and pick up trash.
So kudos to you, for in
a short amount of time,
creating such a strong
culture, because culture
happens in one of two
ways-- either by design,
or by benign neglect.
And all too often I
see benign neglect
taking the stage, people not
really trying to mold it,
just letting it happen.
I also want to open
up, and I talked
to [? Marjay ?] about this--
if you have questions,
if you have comments,
let's open up right now
and say it's OK to do that.
We have a microphone
we're going to run around.
Please don't hold back.
If you're sitting there
thinking, well, yeah,
Doug, it sounds great,
but how do you do it,
or what does that really mean,
or I agree, or I disagree,
let me know.
Does anybody have any
questions-- any clarification
necessary at this time?
We've got mic runners.
Where's the mic?
Right there.
All right, anybody?
Yes, sir, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'd love to hear
more about how you
got beyond the cognitive
level of helping people absorb
that culture and even
the reinforcement.
DOUG LIPP: Getting beyond the
cognitive level is really--
what was being said in the
classroom in the Disney
University was happening
every day on the job.
And so it didn't remove it
from the cognitive level.
It just blended the cognitive
and the gut level into one.
There was congruence
between the message,
because in the
University, we had
people who had
operations background.
Operations people
always filtered
through the University.
So when you walked out as
a newly hired employee,
or as a mid-level manager,
or when Michael Eisner
joined the company-- and I had
him in the Disney University.
In fact on the
back of that book,
you'll see Michael wrote
a testimonial saying, when
I joined Disney as the CEO,
I had to go back to school,
to the University-- when the
CEO walks into the University
as the equivalent
of a Noogler, that
sends a massively powerful
message to everybody
else in the organization.
When I was in charge of training
at Disney Studios, that's
a whole different ball
game, training 35-
to 85-year-old
Hollywood executives--
they're a tough crowd-- versus
the bright-eyed, bushy-tailed
kids you get at Disney
World or Disneyland.
I wasn't going to fight
the battle of having
a discussion about
creativity with them.
I would call in the chairman of
Disney Studios, Dick Cook, who
was in charge of running
a huge corporation.
He's the man who
brought in Johnny Depp
to do all the "Pirates" series.
When he walked in
a room and said,
hey, let's have a
discussion for 30 minutes
about the creative process
of creating a film,
you capture people's
hearts and minds.
And that was the
message is that, if it's
good enough for a
16-year-old new hire,
it's good enough for
that senior executive
and everybody in between.
So that became part
of the culture.
And when it becomes
part of the culture,
you take it out of
the cognitive realm
and you put it
right in the heart.
All right, so let's push on.
Again, in short, the
Disney University
is not a standalone
fix-it operation.
It's a vehicle for the
culture of the organization.
It's part and parcel to what
the company's all about.
So what I'm showing
you right now--
and it really does feed
in nicely, in fact.
Thank you for the cue.
You'll get your bonus
after the presentation's
over-- Van France,
again, my mentor, talked
about why does the
University survive?
And I have to tell you as a
training and development OD
specialist-- I
consult with companies
all around the
world-- all too often
I have people who will challenge
me and say, well, of course,
the Disney University
has success.
I mean, if I had
Mickey Mouse leading
a cheer for my
employees, I'd have
no problem getting
people in the room.
If I had posters of Walt
Disney holding all of his Oscar
awards, I'd have no problem.
In fact, the Oscar the Walt won
for "Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs" is really cool.
Has anybody ever seen it?
It's-- of course the
AV guy's seen it--
the other old guy in
the room has seen it--
it's a single Oscar with seven
baby Oscars lined up next
to it, representing the seven
dwarfs-- posters of that,
pictures of that,
all over the company.
So their point-- non-Disney
people will say, well, yeah,
if I had those fanciful names
and the soundtrack of "Lion
King" and "Hakuna Matata"
playing in the background
when I go in to
orientation, of course
I'm going to be thrilled.
And I say, yes, but what if
that message that you learned in
that training program is not
alive and well on the front
lines?
And that new hire, or
that senior executive,
goes into the park, or goes
back to his or her job,
and somebody else
says, I don't care
what they say in that
brainwashing factory called
Disney University.
The real message is right
here, so forget all that crap.
That would be a
complete waste of time.
And all too often, I
go into organizations,
and I actually recommend they
get rid of their training
department, or at least
their training curriculum,
because it's not in
tune with real life.
And I'm a firm
believer in training.
Everybody should have training.
But it doesn't always
have to be in a classroom.
It could be one-on-one.
It could be mentoring.
It could be in five-minute
bursts throughout the day
or throughout the week.
But this is what-- again
getting back to these four
circumstances that Van
France talked about,
and I write about
extensively in "Disney U,"
because "Disney U," the
book, is about values that
are timeless and applicable
in the organization.
And I work with hospitals.
I work with mom and pop
stores, and everything
in between-- so Van
said this new baby
in the corporate family
would not have survived,
were it not for four
circumstances-- essentially
four values, and these
values represent, I think,
the essence of the
Disney organization,
and I think of all the
companies that I've
worked with over the years,
you can relate to this
more so than anybody.
So the first one is that
Disney as an organization
of innovation.
You know about innovation.
There's nothing to
talk about here,
but what I want
you think about is
with your own approach in
sales or services, how much
do you innovate?
Yes, the company
is known for this.
You've got Google X.
You've got innovation time.
You've got all kinds of
things, but how much are
you personally challenging
yourself every day
to innovate and take
calculated risk?
It's about support--
leadership support--
the example I just gave you
of Dick Cook, the chairman
of Disney Studios,
coming in and leading
a 30-minute discussion
about creativity,
or the chairman of
Disney Imagineering,
a guy named Marty Sklar, who
would also work with executives
and front-line
employees to develop
creative approaches
to solving problems.
He had something that he
called "the white sheet
of paper approach."
He writes about it
in one of his books.
And my wife and I were
recently with them,
spending a whole weekend with
him going over some things,
and we're going to see
him tomorrow night.
He said, my staff of Imagineers,
of animators, of creative types
had massive stress.
There's 11 Disney theme
parks around the world--
soon to be 12, with
Shanghai opening next year.
And he said, the
pressure to outdo
what you just did last
year in that theme park,
or on that ride, or in
that movie is massive.
And so the metaphor that he
used was this piece of paper.
He said, it's like staring
at a blank piece of paper--
even if it's a computer
screen, it doesn't matter--
but that blank piece of
paper scared the heck out
of a lot of my Imagineers.
And so I said-- this is Marty
now-- and so I said to them,
you can look at that blank sheet
of paper in one of two ways.
You can look at it and say, oh
my gosh, I'm so intimidated,
because I have to put the
first words on that paper.
Or you can look at it
and say, oh my gosh,
isn't this exciting?
I'm the one who gets
to be the one who
writes the first
words on this paper.
So that's innovation.
That's support from a
guy named Marty Sklar,
who himself was a writer,
who himself pitched directly
to Walt Disney the idea for the
$0.10 Disneyland newspaper that
was sold for years on
Main Street of Disneyland.
And he pitched that
idea to Walt Disney
when he was a junior at UCLA.
So it can happen at any level.
Thankfully your corporation
encourages innovation,
and you have tremendous support.
It's about education and
the value of education.
Another, I think,
eerily similar value,
and something that's happening
right here in this room today,
is something that happened
at the Disney Studios.
In the mid-1930s,
Walt Disney wanted
to send his animators
to art school
to help them be more
creative, and he
found that the art
schools of the day
were very limited in their
scope of creativity, actually.
They actually forced people
into certain boxes and drawing
styles that Walt didn't
support, but again,
in his inimitable style of
"no, because as opposed to yes,
if"-- let's forget about sending
our people to art school.
Let's invite thought
leaders into Disney Studios.
And this is in the 1930s.
He actually invited
Frank Lloyd Wright
to come in and talk
to the animators
about how to draw
a better Bambi.
What is the connection there?
What they wound up doing,
was they brought a live deer
into the sound stage,
and they put it
on a pile of alfalfa hay.
Now the deer is
munching on alfalfa hay.
And then around the deer
sit a bunch of animators,
ostensibly viewing a deer
in its natural resource,
moving and eating.
In the day that was
mind-alteringly creative,
because up until that
point animators had
to look at real fuzzy
black and white films,
or they had to look
at photographs.
They didn't actually
get to see the muscle
twitch of the animal,
or how the jaw moved
when it ate the alfalfa.
And after listening to Frank
Lloyd Wright come in and give
them ideas about
what he went through
to create a new
building, they did that.
Education and
constantly learning--
what you're doing
with the author series
is exactly that-- constantly
looking at new ideas,
and if you can just pick up one
or two snippets of information,
you're farther ahead
than anybody else.
And then finally,
it's about entertain--
having some fun--
having some fun.
One of my most favorite
Walt Disney quotes,
and it's-- again, for those
of you lucky few who picked up
this book.
It's actually put it
on the inside jacket,
because I love it
so much, and this
is the quote-- "when
the subject permits,
we let fly with all the satire
and gags at our command."
And here's the key-- "laughter
is no enemy to learning."
"Laughter is no
enemy to learning."
It doesn't mean
that you belittle
learning opportunities.
It means that you
make them enjoyable.
make them memorable.
And so that's part of
the answer, gentleman
in the back-- that guy in
blue shirt that asked me--
oh, wake up, yep, yep, yep,
you're back on stage, OK--
that's how you take it
from the cognitive realm
and move into the heart,
is you make it memorable,
and you make it sink in.
Yes, it's important.
But let's not make it
mind-numbingly boring.
The other reason
you are so blessed,
is you live within-- depending
on the time of day-- right
now would be at least
an eight-hour commute
to downtown San Francisco.
Take one of your Google
vans, and go ahead
and get past all the people
that are complaining about that,
go to the Presidio, and go to
the Walt Disney Family Museum.
Has anybody ever been there--
the Walt Disney Family--
isn't that a beautiful property?
It is a great place.
It's only five years old.
It was started by
Walt's daughter Diane.
My wife and I have been
working with museum
for the last couple of years
and looking at opportunities
to turn that museum into a
living laboratory, because it's
full of examples of creativity
and dealing with adversity,
and there is a great
little example of entertain
and educate at the same time.
Of all of the beautiful displays
that are in this museum,
the one that caught
my eye the most
was a small piece of
paper that was framed.
And it had a fanciful
picture of a guy.
It was a cartoon
that Walt Disney
had drawn as a high
school student.
So I can only imagine Walt
Disney as a high school
student sitting in some boring
lecture, just doodling away.
And the quote at the top of
that is what caught my eye.
And it says this-- "develop
your sense of humor,
and eventually it
will develop you."
"Develop your sense of
humor, and eventually
it will develop you."
And that's the essence of what
the Disney organization is all
about, is entertain and
educate at the same time.
Comments, questions,
clarification-- anybody at all?
AUDIENCE: How do you-- and I'm
an instructional designer here,
so trainer-- how do you,
in that new hire level,
stop some maybe bad
cultural traits that
are possible with that kind
of mythos that comes up,
such as traits like entitlement,
or these types of things that
might happen, or
could possibly be
a true aspect of the current
culture at said organization?
I know you said you were
going to talk about how
your organization perhaps
almost failed twice.
And I'm not trying to be
rude or anything like that.
I'm really curious about this.
DOUG LIPP: You're way too nice.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no, no I
don't want this to been seen--
I promise I'm not trying to
be facetious or sarcastic--
I actually really care.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DOUG LIPP: Thank you.
Thank you for asking, and
the point that you bring up
is something that every
organization sooner or later
faces.
And most organizations
do a terrible job
of dealing with it.
In fact, they realize
after the fact
that it's happened to them.
So I'm going to answer your
question in a little bit
roundabout way.
But keep my feet to the flames.
If I don't zero in on what
you're asking, get back to me,
OK?
Specifically, he's saying
in the onboarding experience
for the new hire, how
do you set that tone?
I think it's that
and everything else,
because what
oftentimes happens, A,
the onboarding experience
is too late, in my opinion.
And I know that Google has a
tremendously unique interview
process.
That's where most
organizations fall flat.
I call it hire right,
train right, treat right.
That's the consultant
response-- hire right.
Get the right people on board.
I don't care how well-developed
your onboarding process is,
or how well-developed
your mid-career training
programs are, if you
have the wrong substrate
from the get go, you're done.
So make sure you get the
right people on board,
and then you make sure that
you onboard them properly,
and properly is a loaded term.
I mean, at Disney it
is very methodical.
I understand that at Google--
depending on the position
you're in-- sometimes
you're kind of thrown
into the deep end, and you get
to figure it out on your own,
but that is something that
you buy into when you're
going through the
interview process.
That's part of the
culture, is you have to go
and figure it out on your own.
If I did that in another
company that for decades
has had a methodical
onboarding process,
that won't be fair to new hires.
So get the right
people on board,
train them properly
for their jobs,
but then don't think of that
onboarding as the one shot
inoculation.
It has to be an ongoing process
of continuous education.
So let me just show
some slides to you.
In the evolution
of an organization,
you're going to
expand, hopefully,
into lots of different markets.
You're going to expand in
the kinds and types of people
you hire and serve.
And what I'm showing here,
through these circles,
is different cultures.
It could be linguistic
differences.
It could be cultural
It could be age differences,
regional differences.
And unfortunately,
all too often,
as organizations evolve,
get bigger, more people,
these turn into silos.
And they don't
talk to each other.
It's a day shift.
It's a night shift.
It's the people that come in
direct contact with customers,
or people in back rooms
that are grinding out code.
Those become islands.
Disneyland is no
different than that.
I mean, you think about
the setup of Disneyland
alone-- Fantasyland
is a culture.
Tomorrowland is a
culture unto itself.
Frontierland is
the Wild Wild West.
But one of the things
that we made clear--
and I'm guessing Google
does the same thing--
is you have a massively
clear set of values.
Despite those values,
you still have
to let individuals
do things their way.
And as our globe shrinks, and
we have more multicultural, more
multilingual teammates,
associates, clients,
we have to be able
to say, what's
going to be appropriate
for this group
right now, and appropriate
for that group right now?
What I'm showing right
now is an example of this.
I got to work on "Pirates
of the Caribbean,"
which is decidedly the coolest
culture in all of Disney,
because you can actually
be rather rude to guests,
and you can get away with it.
(SHOUTING) Get in the boat now!
(LITTLE BOY VOICE) Oh, Daddy,
isn't he a swell pirate?
But three hours
later, you might be
over on the attraction (SINGING)
it's a small world after all,
and you've got to be so
nice and saccharin-- that's
a different culture.
But the culture of Disney--
to create the happiest place
on earth, which I find--
correct me if I'm wrong,
but in some of my
research of Google--
"the happiest place
on Earth" is how
everybody relates at Disney.
Yours is "don't be evil."
My god, go to the
negative, why don't you?
Jeez, that's really scary--
anyway, our "don't be evil"
is "create the happiest
place on Earth,"
but so that we connect with all
these different cast members,
we let pirates create the
happiest place on earth
the way pirates would, and
the people on Small World,
the way Small World would.
So we allow a modicum
of flexibility
within the confines of
the overall culture.
But that's the key, is
that the overall culture
is brutally, massively clear.
It's not a moving target.
And I see that as a
challenge for every manager
in every company,
especially newly
promoted managers and
supervisors who, unfortunately,
are oftentimes
promoted because they
are an expert on
their topic, but they
don't know a darn thing
about managing people.
So I would encourage, if
you're a designer for new hire
orientation, think about how do
you keep those newly promoted
people up to speed as well.
Questions, comments, anybody?
You see how it leads to
different discussions
when wacky questions
come up like this?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: You've
addressed quite well
how to find the right
people and build them
up as they come on board.
But sometimes in an
organization of our age,
we have people who are
already entrenched--
DOUG LIPP: Who are what?
AUDIENCE: Entrenched-- they've
been there for a while.
Maybe they're really
good for their jobs,
but they're not that
great for the culture.
How can you, as a
team, when you're
trying to build this
awesome culture,
work around those people,
or bring them around,
our maybe both, or either one?
What do you do
with those people?
DOUG LIPP: Wow, you know,
we've rehearsed this for hours,
and the timing is perfect.
How do you get people to
move beyond being entrenched?
Excellent point.
You all have pieces of
paper in front of you.
In fact, this piece of paper,
this beautiful color copy
has six key lessons.
These are all just part of what
I talk about in "Disney U."
I'm addressing just a
couple of these today.
What I want to do is not look
at that, but flip it over.
How's that?
Go to the backside, where it's
just a blank piece of paper.
And I know that a couple of you
came in with pens or pencils,
if you have an extra pen loan
it to the person next you who
doesn't have a pen.
If you don't have
a pen, you're just
going to do it with your finger.
But we're going to do a
writing exercise for moment,
and this addresses creativity.
This addresses leadership.
This addresses
getting out of a rut.
Everybody have a
pen in your hand?
Hold it up in the air.
All right, loosen up
that wrist a little bit.
I don't want anybody to
get carpal tunnel syndrome
or repetitive motion injury.
All right, that's good.
What I'm going to
have you do-- I'll
give you a
five-second countdown.
And I'm going to have you
sign your name as many times
as you can.
For a warm up, sign your
name one time right now
on that piece of
paper-- just one.
Sign it.
You got it?
You're looking at it.
You're smiling.
Everybody does that.
They look at their
name, and they
smile, because we've all
practiced that signature
since we were in fourth grade.
And we love our signature.
Now, five seconds, and after
that five seconds what you're
going to do, is you're
going to continue
to sign your name
as many times as you
can nonstop for 30 seconds.
I will keep track
of the time-- five,
four, three, two, one, begin.
30 seconds nonstop-- sign your
name as many times as you can.
You've gone 15 seconds.
You're probably
cramping up already.
That's OK.
Push through the pain.
10 seconds, keep going.
All right, shake out that hand.
Get rid of the cramps.
Now analyze your
handwriting two ways.
One, do a productivity
assessment-- how many times
did you actually sign your name?
Write that number down.
Don't look at your neighbor.
It doesn't matter
if you did more.
You are such a type
a competitive group.
Just relax .
Their name might have more
letters in it than yours.
So do a productivity
assessment--
how many times did
you sign your name?
Then I want to do a
quality assessment,
using a 1 through 10 scale.
10 is perfect-- oh
my gosh, that's mine.
1 is who wrote this
chicken scratch?
10 is great.
One is terrible.
Or something in
between for a quality
score-- purely subjective.
You all have that?
Look at me.
Give me feedback.
This is yes.
This is no, and this is
what is this guy doing?
Now, with pen in dominant
hand, hold that in the air,
or if you did air writing,
just hold your blank hand
in the air.
Keep that hand in the air.
Raise your non-dominant hand.
Both hands are in the air.
Transfer the pen to
the non-dominant hand.
Hands down.
Five, four, three, two, one,
proceed-- same exercise,
30 seconds with your off-hand.
No laughing-- this is a
very important exercise.
Stop writing.
Do me a favor.
Look at your neighbor's
and laugh uncontrollably.
Do a productivity assessment.
How many times did
you sign your name
with your non-dominant hand?
Write that number down.
Next is that quality
score, and this
is how you're going to
get it-- this 1 to 10
scale-- look at
your dominant hand
as the benchmark of excellence.
That's the perfect model.
Compare and contrast-- if your
non-dominant hand looks exactly
like that, give yourself
a 10 for quality.
Otherwise, drop it down the
scale accordingly-- five,
three, one, zero,
minus 1 million--
whatever you think you deserve.
Take a couple seconds.
Get that down.
Three questions-- please,
raise your hands in response.
Everybody, I want you
to respond to this.
How many saw a drop-off
in your productivity
the second time around?
Raise your hands.
Look around the room--
beautiful-- hands down.
How many saw a
drop-off in quality
the second go around--
beautiful, hands down.
Last question, how many felt
uncomfortable or downright
foolish the second go
around-- beautiful.
That's the answer
to your question.
We get stuck in ruts because
we don't want to look stupid.
We don't want to fail.
Metaphorically, as
a coach of others--
even when working with clientele
in sales and services--
I, as a change-agent,
need to recognize the pain
I'm putting through
that changee.
Even myself-- I am not
comfortable looking foolish.
I don't know how to
manage people that way.
But I'm not going to let
on that I don't know.
We all have egos-- individually,
as well as organizationally.
And metaphorically,
the challenge
is are you willing and able
to move the pen from one hand
to the other?
It doesn't mean that you're
giving up that dominant hand
and skill set.
It means that
you're adding to it.
And the reason I feel
strongly about this--
and I'm going to talk about
it as we go along here--
is that we at Disney became
so confident and competent
with our dominant hand,
that we forgot to change.
You think left and
right, dominant hand
or non-dominant hand, now
let's change it to people.
Dreamers and doers represent
the far ends of that continuum.
Continuum is what we in
the OD business call it.
It's just a, line for crying
out loud, but it's a line,
and on the far end what
we're showing up on
the screen now is Walt
was on the dreamer
end of the continuum.
What if?
What are we going to do?
It's Google X, right?
And you have to make
things go to market.
You got to make money.
You got to make
it happen somehow.
You got to produce this thing.
So you have to have doers.
Walt Disney and his brother
Roy were the classic balance
of dreamer, doer.
You don't agree with
everything they say.
But at least you have
that contrarian thinker.
Teams that have both
are amazingly strong.
But unfortunately, only about
7% of companies around the world
have a succession plan.
And we at Disney
fell into that trap.
With both dreamers and
doers on your team--
regardless of how old
they are or how many years
of experience--
you will continue
to dominate your market.
You will continue to have
a culture that evolves,
challenges itself.
But with one, you're done.
So I want to share with
you a quote, again,
from this gentleman
Marty Sklar that
spent 53 years in his career
with the Disney organization,
and he talked about the
mindset that Walt Disney had.
Walt Disney in, Marty's words,
as I'm showing on the screen,
"always had one foot in the past
and one foot in the future."
He recognized the importance
of the legacy of the company.
And legacy is a relative
term-- for some companies
it's 16 years, for some
companies it's decades,
for some it's just
a couple of years.
In Silicon Valley, a long legacy
is a day, and you're done.
It's OK.
But he, meaning Walt,
didn't hang out in the past.
He knew that it was
important to leverage
that to go to the future
and upset the apple
cart, constantly moving
the pen, metaphorically,
left to right, right to left.
But when Walt passed
away, the tendency
was for the doer
mindset to take over--
not upset the apple cart,
not make any mistakes,
keep the pen in
that dominant hand.
Another way to look at it is
something called the "S curve."
Has anybody ever
studied the S curve?
You might want to Google it.
Check it out.
But it's also known
as the sigmoid curve.
Now if you've had
a sigmoidoscopy,
you don't want to
think about that.
So we'll just call the S curve.
But it's basically the letter
"S" kind of lying on its side.
And it basically represents
the beginning, middle, and end.
It's a life cycle of
anything-- an idea, a product,
a color scheme, hairstyles,
whatever the case might be.
And if you have dreamers
and doers on a team,
then you're guaranteed of
having multiple S curves going
in the air, and many things
being juggled at the same time.
If you only have
one or the other,
generally, the marketplace
has changed around you,
and you didn't realize it,
or you're producing products
that nobody cares about anymore.
And most organizations
don't change
until they get to point
z, and that's too late.
And this is exactly what
happened to us at Disney.
When Walt Disney
passed away, and we
lost that creative
force, and the person who
was willing and able to
upset the apple cart,
and everybody was busy
circling wagons to make sure
that nothing changed,
we got in trouble.
So I want to think about--
this quote right now,
I think, is particularly
poignant for Google.
You're at your 10th
anniversary of your IPO.
This quote is from Walt
Disney at the 10th anniversary
of Disneyland.
Disneyland opened in '55.
This is from a meeting that
he had with his executive team
and operations team in 1965.
And of many things
that he said, he said,
we've had 10 years of
knock-the-ball-out-of-the-park
success.
And he talked about
all the accolades
from around the world of
starting this theme park called
Disneyland that no one had
ever dreamed of before.
In the past, it was you
should go to the state fair.
Or you go to a county fair.
And you know what kind
of quality you get there.
And Walt said,
but you know what?
I look at these first
10 years as nothing more
than a dress rehearsal-- nothing
more than a dress rehearsal.
And if any of you
on this team think
you can rest on your laurels,
then there's the door.
That's what keeps an
organization young and dynamic,
is you've always got
that pressure to perform.
And you can look at
that as massive stress.
Or you could look at as
tremendous opportunity.
And when Walt passed away, some
of that went away with him.
Another thing that
went away with him--
and this is another part about
keeping an organizational
culture alive and well-- is
a term that we use a Disney
called "plussing the
show"-- improving the show.
I'll give you one
specific example
that I write about
in "Disney U."
One of the directors of
the Disney University
told me a story about when
he was an 18-year-old ride
operator at Disneyland.
And Walt Disney came into
the park all the time.
Walt was known to walk the park.
He was always in direct contact
with guests and cast members.
Walt Disney rode
on jungle cruise?
Anybody ever ridden on
Jungle Cruise before?
Fantastic ride.
And Walt gone off of the boat--
there are seven boats on jungle
cruise-- he got off of the boat
and pulled all the skippers off
to the side on the
dock to give them
some fairly critical feedback.
He said, we've got
to plus the show.
If we don't plus the
show we'll lose guests,
and it will take us
years to get them back.
And this is the specific
example he gave-- he said,
we've invested
millions of dollars
in this attraction--
in the soundtrack,
in the audio
animatronic figures.
And he said, and each of
you skippers undermine that.
And this guy said, well,
what do we do, Walt?
He said, well, you
think about it.
In this seven-minute
ride, when we
get to about the
middle of the ride
where the jungle is
encroaching on us,
and the boats are getting into
that real, dark scary part
of the jungle, and the river
is really dark, dark green,
what happens at
that moment, when
everybody's on pins and needles?
And the skippers all said, well,
that's when the hippos jump out
of the water-- the hippopotamus.
And Walt said, exactly.
And what do those hippos do?
Well, they roar.
And they scream.
And they spit water.
He said, yes, and they
spit water on the guests,
and they make noise.
And what are the
guests are doing?
Well, they're screaming
with delight and fright.
Exactly, said Walt.
What were each of
you skippers doing?
And then Walt
demonstrated to them--
this is driving a boat-- [YAWNS]
another day, another hippo.
You killed the show.
You've got a week to
practice looking surprised.
And this guy that I
interviewed, he said,
and you can only
imagine how many hours
we spent the next week
practicing looking surprised,
knowing full well that
Walt was going to be back.
And he said, but what was
interesting about this process,
was that at first it was just
pretending to look surprised.
But then, as we did
it more and more,
we realized this is a brand
new boatload of guests,
and for then this is a
brand new experience.
And we started to
feel their excitement.
So here is Walt Disney, again.
This brilliant man who
said, millions of dollars
invested in the hardware,
but you're the software.
How much does a smile cost?
That keeps an
organization fresh,
and it's an example
of plussing the show.
It means that we
all make mistakes.
This artwork is from another
book that I wrote years ago.
It's from a proverb
that I learned in Japan.
And the proverb is this--
even monkeys fall from trees.
No matter how good you are, no
matter your name recognition--
domestically or
internationally--
you will screw up.
And all too often, organizations
and individual managers
blame that metaphorical gust
of wind, or the broken branch,
for the reason they're
flat on their backside,
as opposed to looking in
the mirror and assessing
how they could improve.
So here is something I'd
like to share with you,
and then I'm going to start
to bring this to a close.
This is a picture of that
wonderful, beautiful man,
Van France.
This is the guy that created
the Disney University.
How many of you been
to the Disney Institute
with the B.A. Program?
Some of you?
I heard that quite a few,
actually, at Google do.
The Disney Institute is
the for-public version
of the university,
which Van started.
So this set of words is part
of a memo than Van France sent
to Walt Disney and something
called the Park Operating
Committee to challenge
them on being more creative
in being better leaders,
creating better training,
keeping the product fresh.
Look at the word choice in here.
Has anybody ever used
the word "arthritis
of the imagination," or
"cirrhosis of the enthusiasm"?
And this is the
brilliance of Van France--
just like Walt Disney-- really,
really honest, brutally honest,
and a great salesperson.
He knew that if he
didn't package a memo
in a creative enough way, that
Walt and the team of executives
wouldn't pay any
attention to it.
So my question to
you is this, who
is the Van France on your team,
within sales and services?
Who is the person
who's not afraid to say
what he or she sees?
Now, I understand in any
organization there's always
going to be politics involved,
but people like Van France
always find ways to get the
truth to the right people.
So I'm going to finish up
with another little exercise,
just to have you get
a little bit of energy
before you got to go back
out into the Bay area traffic
and drive home.
I want you think
about creativity.
Something as simple as
"how clean is clean?"
Before we opened
Tokyo Disneyland,
the team of custodians
that I hired and trained
made a huge mistake.
The night before our
first mini-grand opening,
we had executives
from the United States
tell them, hey, go out
tonight, and clean the park,
because Disney is
known for cleanliness.
And we had spent months training
them on cleaning the park.
And it was all interpreted
perfectly well.
And so they said,
yes, we understand.
We're going to clean the park.
This is the graveyard crew--
midnight, 3 o'clock, 4 o'clock,
everything goes fine.
4 o'clock in morning,
I get a phone call
from a very upset
American executive.
What is wrong with those
custodians you hired
and you trained?
And I said, nothing-- we
hired the best custodians
from around the country.
He said, well, then
answer me this,
why did they clean
The Haunted Mansion?
I said, what's the problem?
It's supposed to be clean.
He says, no, no,
you don't get it.
They fixed all the
broken windows.
They vacuumed up all the dust.
All the spider webs are gone.
Literally in about
four hours, they
had cleaned away a quarter
million dollars of artwork.
It no longer looked
spooky and scary.
It looked like an
operating room.
And the trouble was this-- and
we did a root cause analysis--
it's because we trained them
in backstage areas that weren't
aged and grained-- kitchens,
restrooms, break areas that
had a lot of stainless
steel and white tile.
And when they would
scrub it until it shined,
we would say, bravo, good job!
And they took that same approach
into The Haunted Mansion.
So again, communication
is not easy.
And as our teams
get more diverse,
based on age,
ethnicity, culture,
it gets even more complicated.
So I'm going to finish
this with that story.
It's written about
in "Disney U."
I want to thank you all
so much for your time.
I know but you've got
very, very busy schedules.
Keep up the good work
and keep your culture
alive and well
and ever-evolving.
Thank you so much.